I truly can't believe this is happening.
But Kellyanne Conway, a top adviser to Donald
Trump, seems to think Cauvin, 19, means that
it's the 19th Corona virus.
Of course, Koven, 19, is a reference to twenty
nineteen, the year in which this virus was
evolved, demerged was named.
There is really not much need for more explanation.
Donald Trump yesterday announced that he's
cutting funding to the W.H.O. in the midst
of a pandemic.
It's a disastrous decision.
Kellyanne Conway, of course, went on Fox News
and she's trying to defend everything that
Donald Trump does, trying to defend Donald
Trump from scrutiny, trying to defend Donald
Trump's action in cutting funding to the W.H.O..
And she says, hey, guys, come on.
This is covered 19, not covered one.
The W.H.O. should have figured it out by now.
And of course, Cauvin, 19 just means Corona
virus disease from the year 2019.
Here's Kelly-Anne in her full glory.
The president took decisive and immediate
action.
End of January to shut down flights from China.
That was criticized by the W.H.O..
It was criticized by other people as xenophobic
and racist.
And travel bans don't work.
Well, this one sure did.
So we have every right to know and every right
to know because of what's happened here in
this global pandemic.
But there's another reason some of the scientists
and doctors say that there could be other
strains later on.
This can come back in the fall in a limited
way.
This is covered 19 that covered one, folks.
And so you would think that people charged
with a World Health Organization facts and
figures would be on top of that, that this
is just a pause right now.
So there is an investigation examination to
what happened.
But people should know the facts.
How dystopian is it that she ends with?
People should know the facts.
Despite spreading something that is not a
fact but is rather completely false propaganda.
This is covered 19 folks, not covered one.
That's just the year.
This isn't the 19th Corona virus.
I hope that all of you understand the implication,
which is if this is the 19th such corona virus,
how the hell has the W.H.O. not prepared during
corona viruses one through 18?
That's not what it means.
It just means this is the twenty nineteen
corona virus.
That's it.
Now I suspect and I'm curious what you think.
I suspect Kellyanne Conway knows that Koven
19 doesn't mean this is the 19th Corona virus.
I think she knows it means it's the twenty
nineteen corona virus.
I think Kellyanne Conway is saying this because
she's on Fox and it's likely to stick with
a ton of their viewers.
This was sort of useful to me and that I thought
the movie Canine Cop was the ninth movie.
And I've been asking my mom since I was a
little kid, can't we rent, you know, canine
cop one through one through eight?
Turns out they weren't really movies.
Turns a new leaf over for Blink 182.
Now I'm understanding where all of the other
bands, many questions really being answered
for me by Kellyanne Conway here.
But this is a top adviser to the president,
top adviser.
I do thank Kellyanne Conway to remind the
audience that covered 19 by mentioning 2019
is another reminder that this was around last
year.
Trump did nothing until February, but it was
identified last year.
We started tracking it last year.
We were following case numbers last year,
not in late February when Donald Trump finally
started doing something about it.
Now, one other word about the W.H.O.. Trump
announced yesterday he's cutting funding to
the W.H.O., talked a lot about China or China,
as he calls it.
And it's a lot of blame shifting and trying
to blame everybody and take no responsibility.
Just because Trump said he's cutting funding
to the W.H.O. doesn't mean he actually is.
And I'm not saying anything other than Trump
has many times announced that he's doing things
and he never does it.
Remember when he announced the transgender
military ban while his then secretary of state,
secretary of defense was.
Who knows where.
Nobody knew about it.
And then it wasn't ever actually done.
And nobody talks about it anymore.
Very often, Donald Trump will announce something
and then it doesn't really happen.
That doesn't mean it's right to announce it
if he's not actually doing it.
All I'm saying is Trump made an announcement
of something that is a bad idea.
We don't actually know whether it's going
to happen.
He claims it is.
We don't know because he lies all the time